meet the fellows event
the first talk of the last session is uh
by eric mazumba from catholic
cool
yeah thank you
um and so today i'm gonna be talking
about
kind of a line of work on learning in
the presence of strategic agents
and i'm going to start really really
high level and then hopefully i'll get
down into some of the details um but i
just want to start with this very
obvious observation that we're
increasingly interacting with learning
algorithms either unknowingly or
knowingly every single day so when we're
you know ordering something on ubereats
or reading the cartoon on the new yorker
we're implicitly interacting with some
form of a learning algorithm i think
this just goes to show how these
algorithms have just been completely
deployed across the real world
um but as they're actually implemented
in real world settings you know they can
really struggle and in particular they
can struggle in the face of strategic
behaviors so this is one of my favorite
examples it's about a phenomenon known
as surge clubs which happens on ride
sharing markets and so what happens i'll
explain it a little bit is a group of
drivers will all um kind of band
together on uber and they'll go to a
certain area of the city like beverly
hills and they'll turn off their apps at
the same time
then the uber surge pricing algorithm
notices that there's been a sudden dip
in supply
and it'll start surging the price in
that location to attract more drivers
there and then drivers turn on their
apps and then collect the higher search
price
so
you know as a system designers is not
all what i intended because these
drivers are effectively gaming my
algorithm but i think this just goes to
show um the types of behaviors that that
you know algorithms are faced with when
they're deployed into the real world
so
you know this is the type of problem
that i'm interested in kind of
developing algorithms that are robust to
these type of strategic behaviors and
that can reason the face of these
strategic behaviors
so in today's talk i'm going to talk
about kind of three different lines of
work very at a very very high level and
i've kind of aligned them with the three
main topics that will go on in the
learning and games semester at simon's
the first is going to be about
gradient-based algorithms and continuous
games i'll touch very briefly on some of
the implications for multi-agent
reinforced learning and then i'll end on
some
kind of higher level work more kind of
practical work on learning in the
presence of strategic agents
so i'm going to start with
gradient-based algorithms and continuous
games
and the high level question i want you
to keep in mind here is what can we say
about the convergence of gradient-based
learning algorithms in non-convex games
where we lose any types of structure
that have been kind of
classically
been relied on in the learning and games
community and this is kind of a long
line of work
that i've been doing
from my phd all the way to now
with collaborators here at berkeley
and uw
so
um i'm just gonna you know assume that
by now you've seen the definition of
nash equilibria today and so i'll just
kind of give you an idea of the types of
results we get so what we show using
basically dynamical systems and control
theory
is that in non-convex general sum games
gradient play will almost surely avoid a
subset of the nash equilibrium of the
game
and basically what we show is that
nash equilibria can be locally just
straight up unstable in general some
games meaning that even if you
initialize in an arbitrarily small
neighborhood of a nash equilibrium
you'll still diverge and that's because
we can show
that nash equilibria can have basically
the set of initializations from which
you'll converge to nash equilibrium will
just be measure zero in the joint
strategy space
in the context of zero-sum games we show
something a little bit more um kind of
pleasant which is that nash equilibria
are generically stable in zero sum games
and so any non-convergence issues that
you get there are basically just the
results of poor discretizations and
that's kind of nice because it means
that nash equilibria you can always get
you know local last iterate convergence
by doing some kind of
smart discretization tricks like let's
say the proximal point algorithm or
optimism
okay so the second result is that um
in non-convex general some games agents
who basically try and use gradient play
can converge to spurious stationary
points
and so this means that they could
converge to you know local equal
equilibria where in the worst case every
agent has a direction in which they
unilaterally like to deviate to lower
their cost but they can't because of the
uh the algorithms that they're using so
we think of these as being kind of
pretty undesirable equilibria because
they're not necessarily even locally you
know rational
and as from the point this was also
shown at the same time
in the context of zero sum games by by
several people
so
you know i present to this and i think
it's very important to you know point
out that these issues are not just of
purely theoretical interest
and to make it practical i want to you
know take a step into
kind of multi-agent reinforcement
learning world
so you know i don't think anyone here
needs to
a reminder of all the successes of deep
reinforcement learning but you know in
all of these games where deep mind is
playing let's say starcraft and open ai
is playing dota 2. if we look under the
hood the algorithms that they're using
are multi-agent reinforcement algorithms
and in particular they're policy grading
algorithms
so you know we decided to ask a very
simple question which is do policy
grading works in just even simple uh
continuous action space in state space
games so
you know we also looked at you know in
general some linear quadratic games
which if you saw from kaiking's talk um
just before
um i'll
kind of go over what they are so
an lq game is just the generalization of
the lqr problem from kind of classic
control theory and it's you know a very
simple game there's a shared discrete
time dynamical system
um all players have an input to this
dynamical system
and then every player has a loss
function that they want to minimize
which is quadratic in the state of the
system and their own inputs
and then
they're going to optimize over the space
of linearly parametrized policies
so it's a very simple game the space of
kind of
kind of continuous actions and
continuous states
and our goal is just to understand what
happens if you use policy gaining
algorithms in these games
so you know we can show these games are
non-convex we can show that
all local equilibria um for policy
grading algorithms have to be
uh nash equilibria but if we use
policy-grade algorithms in these games
we see that we they converge to kind of
very
non-trivial behaviors in particular
um they converge to cycles and i think
something that i think really sets this
apart from a lot of the work that we
have seen during the workshop and the
bootcamp is that averaging doesn't work
here you can see that on average which
is this dark line
um they don't converge to the nash
equilibrium they convert to something
else
and that's
just because of the fact that you know
these nash equilibria are unstable and
in you know dimension higher than two
you don't have any guarantees that
inside of a limit cycle you have an
equilibrium
so you know we showed that this actually
happened in kind of a large set of
of linear quadratic games in particular
like just by randomly sampling we saw
that this happened
in up to one in four um kind of
general sum multi-agent games
so
you know policy gradients might not be
the way forward
so
you know the takeaway from these first
two parts is that current machine
learning algorithms have no guarantees
of finding game relevant solutions in
continuous games without assuming more
structure
um and if non-confidence and i think an
interesting question is that if
non-convergence isn't a discretization
issue
will optimism and proximal methods still
work
and then the second question is you know
for what classes of games can we
actually give convergence guarantees
um so i you know we saw from kaishin
that they can actually give global
convergence of policy-grade algorithms
in zero-sum games so that was a really
nice result
and then in nurbs this year we were able
to show that in classes of non-convex
non-concave zero-sum games we can
actually give last iterate convergence
to local min max equilibria so
equilibrium that satisfy certain
curvature properties
as long as the two players have a
certain finite time scale separation and
that's kind of using
some interesting kind of lyapunov theory
great and so in the remaining time i
just want to
move on to kind of some much more recent
work
on learning in the presence of strategic
agents and in particular we'd be looking
at the problem of strategic
classification so
um the question kind of overarching
question here
is how should we learn in strategic
classification if strategic agents
gradually adapt to our deployed models
so
the general setup in strategic
classification is that of you know you
have a decision maker and strategic
agents a decision maker wants to
minimize its prediction loss strategic
agents want a favorable predictions out
of this decision maker
and you know they'll deploy the decision
maker deploys a model and then strategic
agents you know will respond
so
in particular strategic agents and
decision makers will adapt to each
other's actions
so you know we ask the question what
happens if this is repeated over and
over and over over time and in
particular if we you know unroll time
and we allow agents and the decision
maker to update you know at perhaps
different time scales
so
what will happen if they're both
adapting to each other over time over
different time scales
and i want to point out that the vast
majority of password and strategic
classification always models agents as
playing an instantaneous best response
so not gradually adapting over time but
always optimally adapting so this is
kind of the main difference in our model
um and so
you know we we kind of make this
observation that
increasingly now because decision makers
are you know tech companies who are
deploying algorithms they can often
choose how fast they learn relative to
the population of users
so in particular a decision maker can be
much much slower relative to the agents
or much much faster relative to the
agents
and you know at a high level what we
show is that if agents
are basically no regret learners
then these two scenarios where the
decision maker is faster where the nurse
is making it slow will lead to
drastically different game theoretic
equilibrium in particular they'll lead
to different stackable equilibria of the
underlying game one
where the decision maker leads and the
other one where the decision maker
follows
and so really the takeaway here is that
the relative learning rate can be used
to select for specific stockoberg
equilibria and strategic classification
so
at a high level the takeaway is just
that when you're learning in the
presence of adaptive no regret strategic
agents the learner the learning rate
doesn't only affect the speed of
convergence to a solution
it actually also affects the type of
solution that you converge to i think
that's a really important um
point to hammer home and so
you know moving forward i think that
there's this really interesting question
which is what other benign design
choices are we making when we are
playing algorithms that actually affect
performance and competitive settings
and so you know i think i want to wrap
up there and just i'm very excited about
you know this entire
semester here at simon's and so if you
have any questions i'd be happy to
answer them and thanks for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
i just uh
i'm just wondering like for the the
second part of the talk when you talk
about uh learning at the faster rate or
a slower rate do we know if the the
convergence point is a nash equilibrium
the next speaker is anish agarwal